hi everyone my name is Tara chambers and
I'm Malcolm ray and this is Tara Jessa
yeah we just uh Black Panther more like
experienced I was already excited for it
because representation matters yes so
far it's an incredible cast of
incredible black actors they are
incredible black actors and it was a
good movie they they went balls deep
into a very like stark issue like the
elephant in the room and the they handle
it really well honestly but the social
commentary wasn't like the for problem
would be like it was subtle and nuanced
because you know the main plot was
basically about T'Challa who was going
to take his place in the throne because
his father died if you haven't seen what
your soldier yet spoilers yes to Chaka
dies this movie picks up where that left
off and now he's you know about to
resume his duties as the royal king then
the heir to the throne and the villain
that he has to face and his personal
story had so much depth to his character
so much unexpected like this may be my
favorite Marvel villains yeah I got a
same-same I don't know how much my
boobie Jordan plays the villain in this
I outrageously good you know the history
of black people in the Americas versus
you know in Africa it's like things
happen a little differently yeah and so
you know it's like Wakanda you where
have you been for the past four or five
hundred years again there's so much
heart in depth to his character that
makes you really feel for the character
but at the same time like dude no don't
do that
super redeemable super redeemed at the
end by like coming and doing in a sense
what he sought out to do he became King
and he influenced Wakanda like they said
yeah yeah
the world is rapidly changing and you
know we need to make sure that we're you
know still ahead of the game and even
though you know he didn't you know
ultimately get his ultimate goal
achieved or accomplished he still
influenced he still impacted Wakanda to
the point where T'Challa finally decided
to start you know reaching out to you
know like black communities in other
countries and he made the outreach
centers like he bought buildings and
he's gonna have him done up and his
sister's gonna be like spearheading the
science department and the smile on her
face when he said that to her was
beautiful but angie was just beautiful
because of that change that was made and
the villains demise at the end his death
scene was just beautiful and so powerful
and you really saw you know he has this
tough exterior he's the villain of the
film and at the end when he like breaks
down he sees the sunset he's beautiful
I'm just like bawling his line was like
because T'Challa offered to heal him of
his mortal wound and Erik's just like Oh
what so you know you can lock me up he
said no and he you know takes the spear
out of his chest and allows himself to
bleed out and he says that his ancestors
knew he's like just bury me in the water
with my ancestors because they knew that
death was better than pondage and I was
just like - the middle passage links
Lee's word they were even slaves yet
they were a jumping ship before they
could become slaves yeah with like
mothers with children they were just
like bye
yeah yeah they're like I'm not gonna be
asleep yeah and what a reference damn
yeah like powerful is hell yeah this
Marvel movie just makes like DC movies
watching just the characters feel these
things and deal with these things it's
so much more interesting to me than like
the action was in this film yeah yeah
like the action was there and it was
yeah but like it was mostly for the plot
and the characters and getting really
engaged in their story I love that his
suit is so powerful and such a badass
thing but his character and his his
backgrounds and just culture is so
vastly interesting that he's like Batman
but way better yeah he's got this cool
suit that kind of like really helps him
out but way better it looks so much more
depth so much more than the suit is just
kind of like an afterthought I was like
oh yeah he's got that it's been enhanced
by his sister who was like the
scientific you know head in his kingdom
she made a suit where it can like absorb
blows and it builds up the kinetic
energy and he can just discharge at any
point he wants it's really cool but also
the women in this movie oh yeah oh yeah
I forgot that she was in this the
actress that plays Michonne from Walking
Dead is the head general like the
biggest badass fighter she's so badass
in this film I wish that there was like
a compilation video I'm just her scenes
cuz I just watch her over and over made
of vibranium of course oh my god I I
mean we all know I loved Wonder Woman
but the women in this film make Wonder
Woman look like I loved the linework
she's like gun this is so primitive oh
yeah yeah I again Michonne
I guess what sets us apart from the
other Marvel movies is that it's
grounded in reality like you're sitting
there at some point see like it's like
I'm feeling it's kind of real right
there it's like oh is the comedy was
just real and it wasn't forced mm-hmm
there was definite moments of funny
things but it was of like real
situations
whereas a lot of the more recent Marvel
films have which I loved the comedy they
have a lot of comedy in them and this
was more grounded yeah as opposed to
like everyone being written like Tony
Stark don't get me wrong you know but
yeah but it's like you can mix up the
characters like it wasn't like a thor
ragnarok
right exactly it was a serious a spell
yeah you know you felt the weights of
everything like there was a lot at stake
yeah the stakes were pretty high you mmm
that's what makes me kind of rank it
like probably like my favorite movie
right now like the best first year in my
opinion I know other people were gonna
probably argue but for me this was an
important film yeah that's the word for
it I wrote down in my notes that I just
can't wait to see the cosplays yeah you
know the costumes are amazing yeah and
I'm feeling Eric's hair so we'll see
what happens
only part that I wish was a smidgen
different is I the the final scene
between both guys in their suits was a
little dark yeah it was really dark I
like I'm trying to like squint and see
what is happening yes like I can hear
him but yeah you see the action too much
but I will say too that the theater was
sold out we got there and we got the
last three tickets we were sitting in
the second row so like everything was
just like oh so which is amazing but
that might have you know played a part
of that as well but I think a little
dark there for like a final scene I wish
I would have seen it right like you said
yeah it's just it's an important good
superhero film that's just more than
that yeah there's some levels and layers
to it because there was a lot of
research that was done and there was a
lot of heart in this - yes
somebody took care to make sure this
wasn't just you know oh you know African
this wasn't coming to America no
disrespect say coming I like that movie
but this like took it
step beyond that I mean this wasn't like
a movie a Disney film where like it's
about black culture but the main
character is a white guy beautiful movie
lots of color lots of just bright
vibrant colors and it's like different
tribes and kingdoms that came together
and you got to explore the rituals and
yeah I loved yeah the tribes are really
cool to see the differences and the use
of color was so good and I loved it
I am absolutely gonna see it again in
theaters yeah I'm seeing it again
tomorrow with another friend of mine
because I gotta see it if you let me
know when you're seeing it I'll see it
with you awesome
yeah it's just like a thing it's it's
yeah it's it's worth seeing in theaters
for sure a lot of films I'm like I don't
need that theater experience like I can
see it at home so I can wait it's cool
but this see this in theaters yeah it's
it's great thank you so much for
watching thank you so much for joining
me
oh yeah sure this wonderful new home of
yours thank you yes never moving again
awesome thanks for watching guys we'll
see you next week bye
[Music]